it makes you realize the success of
someone in a job is less about that
person than it is about the environment
you create for that person once they
take the job in other words a lot of it
is about us the hiring person not the
person we're hiring that lots and lots
of people can Thrive if they're brought
into an environment that helps them
Thrive you know it's like I don't know
if you're a big sports fan but there are
certain coaches who you know tons of
players go to that the coach reliably
turns them into excellent basketball
players or football players right
another coach is it only works with very
very specific people makes you realize
oh it's about the coach it's not about
the player I always you know how they
always talk about general managers and
sports and they say that guy's really
great at drafting great athletes out of
college and I always think maybe they're
not good at drafting maybe they're just
good at making sure those players
succeed once they arrive
that's a that's the magical piece of it